奪い五分是為納期が長いと面に髪の毛が入ってねが付い穴しちゃうんですよ
こっちの女がもう真っ赤でございます二つ目社長です皆さん私のことバカにしてません
か
知ってるよなカーン前の水アンナどの見てたら皆さんばと思いますよ馬鹿なことしたり
実際に失敗するだろうっていうやつおっなんかやって実際に失敗したりしてるんです
けどもう動画の内容
とか僕のちょっとほど言動とか小動きからびだせやにバカ要素が多すぎると深くさせた
ので今回は僕がですねまぁそれならに人のみ学力があり
し教養もあり勉強もできる頭がよい天才秀才夫ってことちょっと証明しようと思います
僕までせ1ない教養ありますよ
もうね高校の時何でもだけでなぜかこの歌は化すれば彼のことは忘れましょう今の話
ですてる
今回こちらは準備しました効率厨こう一貫校適性検査対策問題集ちいこい元コース何か
というと僕もよくわかりません
またバカとか言われわかる忠孝一貫校なるでしょ
要するに高校までこの回転式でくる中学校のことでしょ
腰県のある中学校のことですね多分あ俺のいた俺の書道の効いたという行為
参考に来たんだ御図顕勉強してた女の子がいましたねという感じであるたぶんこの中に
はその小学校長学校で習う内容のもかなり高いレベルの奴が入っていると思います今回
はこれ立ち始め雪がこの走力のものでときますまあ小学校の内容はから
内容じゃ全然も男として終わりですね今ない私はじめ冊はこの中でてきたにパラパラっ
とめくった問題のパン適量に当ててその問題を解きます5問ぐらいなら5万ぐらい走行
と思いますやっぱその賢い系男子なんで確実に全部答えるんですけども
もしネ申何かのミスで僕が間違えたとしたら僕が今日前髪を3センチ切りますって見
てるとにめちゃくちゃ長いんで前髪が参加
てから決めましょう待って参戦っってヤバくなっちまって3センチてやばいなぁ
いいだろういい今日ちょっと俺が勉強できることを見せたいからそれぞれの発行も
ちょっとねテストに臨もうと思います
待って査定だんだん単にでてたらもうダウンダウン薄々ぞ
ショップとつい3弾たんで他のはぁ話がずれましたよねちょっとさとついさんがダーン
に出てテンションが上がってしまいました
では連動の御門兵が目指すやっていこうと思いますちょっと中身見せるとねほらなんか
色々ねほらねっ
大人の
自重とやつです
これ
きますが来ませんコケ子ですあんまり店鮫国語で飛び上がる同様に飛ぶということは
上がるという言葉が結ば
結びついた言葉がありますこのように2つ以上のこそバカもすべて新たな1つの言葉に
なったものを複合語と言います覚えておきましょう
飛び上がるのパパに飛びなり何ということは2つ考えなさい俺は由緒
とびパネルえっ
飛び跳ねるとアドレスメテオきた瞬間に捨てる起き上がるで飛び起きるとかですね
う ok 正解はと
飛び跳ねるお外世界だそういい
簡単だな小学校ですからねそれぞれもう全然出来上がる前でございます
まあこれもちょっと牛左寄りでここらへんの
この問題ん
[音楽]
やべぇずっと待ってこれはヤバイぞマッサージたらお兄さんの学校の文化祭でおにい
さんが入っている科学研究部の実験視聴して敏夫さんと一緒に参加しました
ここに炭酸水塩酸食塩水成婚7章1個でやるのせい車化ナトリウム水溶液とか小学生は
完売初版山水園3食塩水切開水酸化ナトリウムの5つがあるんですけども臭いをかい
たり触ったり舐めたりしてはいけないでこの
中で実験して塩酸と水酸化ナトリウム水溶液
などれかを見分けてほしいという問題でございますりかですねなるほどね実験して
負けると変わるが版だからあるから青になると歩かれてああんたら単なると賛成で
ございます
さあ賛成と a さんが賛成です直遠征は中世で変化がなくて残りの2つ切開聖戦ば
ナトリウムはアルカリ性これでまるでの実験で塩酸と炭酸水賛成の方に
まひめ城にも確かまでに修理もまぐれ cb 本入れると泡が出てそれが確か生徒だっ
て気がします hcl が反応すんだよね
小学校じゃなくなってきたこんなのねっどっか総額曲って中古一貫校苦労様でござい
ましたねちゃ貧しいが青から赤に変わった3000の方載っちゃってそのドッグ犬
マグネシウムリボン入れて泡が出た方が園さんでございますどうだもう片側炭酸って
これでエンサーが分かります
[音楽]
100にする振りぼれよく覚えてるのこんなのてキリッとマージを使ってまず色の違い
はけるで分けた方達でバグし振り本やらなんか黄巾賊を入れると泡が発生しますそれで
会さんと制作なぞる露木が反応するのでその2つが分かるという仕組みでございます高
3ステップ
正解はあ
砲撃ずり上げ
マグネシウムリボンっていう言葉自体ただ小学校で使わないである意味に家の墓って
書いてあったんですけど問題が遺書
一番後ろ難しそうだな
2巻くらいですとこなこの問題
きます阿弥陀万里なら全平均の家庭の電気使用量のはレートは前記使用料の合計を次の
ように表とボートクラブでまとめました
ちょっと待ってこれ3小学校でこんなのやって6ウズ稼いだ小学校
さっき見ていた蔓なかなかパパっ子いいのか頭を書きなさいとアワーと100-
goes 11ついは4図9
アンズ4
まあ裕子アナ15です今超簡単ですね持っており
ヨムジョン中48162000年の冷蔵庫の電気使用量
なぜ都市のエアコンが
紘希小
っていう風に降ってる持ってる生900初10年の短文以下
水かいいか一家だから含めるとほぼ丸です全部まるで後も問題があったんですけども
15と16
まるまるまるでちょっと答え合わせしてみましょうってことをやっていきましょう
1505系まるまるまる
[音楽]